général train quand vous êtes ancien
chef de mission militaire auprès de
l'onu merci d'être avec nous vladimir
poutine a besoin rapidement d'une
victoire notamment avant le 9 mai à quoi
faut-il s'attendre
oui vous avez raison victoire importante
pour lui la date du 9 mai on le sait est
importante pour les russes la fin de la
grande guerre patriotique qui fait
partie de la propagande asséné en
permanence par le président pour teen et
ceux qui l'entourent le problème c'est
que après les échecs de kiev kharkiv
maintenant ils se concentrent derrière
mario paul qui résistent et on voit bien
dans la voix du président ukrainien
qu'il est important cette résidence est
importante parce que lorsque mario paul
sera tombée et que l'offensive lancée à
partir du nord jim pardon vision et de
mario paul pourrait enfermer l'armée
ukrainienne fado donbass et ça c'est le
deuxième objectif russe or pour obtenir
cette victoire sur l'ensemble du donbass
et du loup basque il faut concentrer les
forces est concentré les forces pour les
russes est actuellement difficile parce
qu'il s'agit de récupérer des forces un
peu de bric et de broc de partout et le
moral n'est pas excellent dans l'armée
russe donc voilà il va y avoir une
pression très forte et beaucoup
d'utilisation en fait de l'artillerie
pour essayer d'écraser les défense
ukrainienne faso face aux russes mario
toile on rappelle ceci l'accès à la mer
d'azov est-ce que d'après vous il faut
s'attendre à d'autres crimes de guerre
alors crimes de guerre oui parce qu'à
partir du moment où vous matraque et
avec l'artillerie des cibles civiles
ce sont des crimes de guerre je rappelle
que dans la guerre les civils ne doivent
pas être ciblés or là à l'évidence ils
le sont mais on voit bien que dans les
zones urbaines il est difficile de faire
la part entre les civils les défenseurs
tout ceci est assez mélangé les russes
accusent naturellement les ukrainiens de
se servir des civils comme de boucliers
humains et les ukrainiens accusent les
russes de faire la même chose donc je
pense qu'un mario paul marc le
malheureusement on va avoir des scènes
assez terrible qui sont j'allais dire de
dans l'air de de la saisie d'une ville
de cette importance alors la dîmière
poutine rejette vous l'avais dit la
responsabilité des crimes de guerre
notamment de butcher cramatte ans que la
guerre de la gare qui était bombardé
vendredi matin est il possible que de
tels actes étaient décidés par des
généraux ou des commandants d'unité sans
l'aval du kremlin alors je crois qu'il
ya deux choses qu'il faut bien observer
d'abord les enquêtes les enquêtes ont
commencé extrêmement tôt et donc il va
falloir voir ce que ces enquêtes
décidé ça n'est pas moi bien sûr un
n'ayant pas tous les éléments qui vais
le faire maintenant la deuxième chose
qu'il faut voir c'est que au delà de ce
que vous dites c'est à dire des
commandants locaux qui auraient pu
donner des ordres ou laisser faire il ya
l'environnement global nous en parler en
toute à l'heure du président poutine du
discours du président poutine et de son
entourage qui a en gros
justifie toute utilisation de la force
pour essayer d'obtenir la décision sur
le terrain dont je crois que les deux
éléments sont importants au passage sur
un plan légal c'est important parce que
le crime de guerre c'est lorsque des
civils sont ciblés quel que soit l'unité
le crime contre l'humanité c'est quand
ces crimes de guerre serait être
politique et sont systématisées et donc
c'est le cas si on s'aperçoit que du
haut en bas de la chaîne des ordres ont
été donnés on a des on a des témoignages
de soldats russes qui refusent
d'exécuter les ordres et qu'il le dise
aux ukrainiens fois un tribunal
international faut avoir des preuves
exactement qui ils ont donné dès que je
dis aujourd'hui c'est que les enquêtes
sur le terrain sont extrêmement
importantes et il faut noter que ces
enquêtes arrivent très très tôt d'abord
par la présence de journalistes
occidentaux indépendant qui permettent
de vérifier ce qui se passe sur le
terrain et ensuite parce que hélas c'est
le travail de ces professionnels
d'accumuler les preuves pour arriver à
démontrer que ç'a été on a on a déjà
identifié une brigade dans la région de
nord ouest de kiev où même le commandant
de la brigade a été identifiée la
brigade a été identifié est ce qu'il a
donné des ordres ou est ce qu'il a
laissé faire pour moi ça revient au même
les crimes de guerre en tout cas elles
vont rendre ni vont rendre les
négociations de plus en plus difficile
sur quoi pourrait-elle porter en dehors
de l'annoncé d'un cessez-le-feu alors il
ya deux éléments la neutralité de
l'ukraine s'est quasiment quelque chose
d'acquis le président ukrainien avait
déjà fait remettre un mémoire écrit dans
lequel il parlait de la neutralité la
grosse discussion ça va être sur les
conquêtes territoriales et c'est là que
les combats qui se déroulent en même
temps que la négociation sont importants
pour les ukrainiens il s'agit d'empêcher
les russes de conc'air tout le dos net
c'est lou bosc pour les russes il s'agit
de le conquérir et ensuite de parler à
dépasser à des négociations qui
pourraient durer des mois des années et
qui se serait le fait accompli sur le
terrain mais quelles concessions peuvent
faire les ukrainiens pour que vladimir
poutine ne soit pas condamné soit à la
défaite soit à l' escalade et bien je
pense que la seule concession qui peut
être fait c'est
ayons un cessez le feu maintenant et
discutons de ces régions plus tard et ça
pour le président russe face à la
population russe à l'ue permettraient
dire victoire vous voyez nous avons
libéré ces populations et maintenant on
va discuter ça va prendre du temps et ça
serait un pis-aller pour le président
ukrainien parce que ça permettrait
d'obtenir un cessez le feu tout de suite
mais sachant qu'on aura créé pardonnez
moi de trouver un parallèle français
l'alsace lorraine de l'ukraine et des
combats qui serait remis à plus tard
donc il faut une porte de sortie pour le
président il faut une il faut une porte
de sortie je suis pas sûr que ni les
russes ni les ukrainiens puisse avoir
une victoire éclatante mais il faut que
leur discours puisse présenter une
victoire merci beaucoup général
trinquant d'être lundi sur france 24